foreign
has grown exponentially over the past
few years and it's no surprise why
devops is a set of practices and tools
that aims to break down the silos
between development and operations team
and streamline the software delivery
process by doing so devops enables
organizations to deliver high quality
software faster and more efficiently
than ever before
if you're interested in pursuing a
career in devops then this video on how
to choose devops as a career is for you
with the proper roadmap on how to get
started with it also do not forget to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn so without any further
Ado let's get started for first is to
understand the role of a devops
professional before diving into the
specifics of how to become a devops
professional it's essential to
understand the roles and
responsibilities of a devops
professional a devops professional is
typically responsible for Designing
implementing and maintaining the
infrastructure automation tools and
processes required for the efficient
delivery of software this includes
collaborating with development teams to
integrate automation into the software
development process setting up and
maintaining the infrastructure required
for the software delivery pipeline such
as servers databases and network systems
developing and implementing automation
scripts to improve the efficiency of
software delivery process
continuously monitoring and analyzing
the software delivery process to
identify and resolve bottlenecks and
improve efficiency
ensuring that the software delivery
process adheres to Industry best
practices and regulatory requirements so
now that you understand the roles and
responsibilities of a devops
professional let's take a let's take a
look at the roadmap to become a devops
professional so first is to learn the
basics of software development to Be an
Effective devops professional it's
essential to have a good understanding
of software development processes
including programming languages software
development methodologies and Version
Control tools
you can start by learning programming
languages like python Java or Ruby well
a devops engineer course will prepare
you for a career in devops Technologies
through this devops engineer course you
will learn to review deployment
methodologies CI CD pipelines
observability and use devops tools like
gate Docker and Jenkins with this devops
engineer certification you can check out
the link for this course in the
description following that learn about
infrastructure and operations as a
devops professional you will be
responsible for managing infrastructure
including servers databases and network
system so it's essential to have a good
understanding of infrastructure and
operations this include learning about
servers operating systems Network
protocols and storage systems
then explore about automation tools and
cloud services
automation is a critical part of devops
learning automation tools such as
ansible puppet or shirt can help you
streamline the software delivery process
and improve efficiency
most organizations today use cloud
services to deliver software
learning cloud services such as AWS
Azure or gcp can help you design and
Implement Cloud architecture that are
efficient and scalable
well to help you with learning devops
and cloud services simply learn has to
offer Azure devops solution expert
master's program to help you become an
industry ready professional
in this course you will learn to plan
smarter collaborate better and ship
faster with a set of modern development
services the link for this course is
mentioned in the description do check
them out
once done with Skilling you need to gain
experience and get certified as
discussed before
it's a way to gain experience in devops
is to work on real world projects this
can be achieved through internships
volunteering for open source projects or
even taking on small projects on your
own this will allow you to put your
theoretical knowledge into practice and
gain hands-on experience
along with it there are various
certification programs available such as
the devops Institute certification
program AWS certification devops
engineer and Microsoft Azure
devopsolutions certification once you
have gained experience and acquired the
necessary skills it's time to start
looking for job opportunities there are
various job titles in devops such as
devops engineer site reliability
engineer automation engineer and release
engineer in top hiring companies in the
field include Amazon Google Microsoft
IBM and many others well a postgraduate
program in devops in collaboration with
Caltech ctme is a professional
development option that will Square your
skills with industry standards in this
course you will learn how to formalize
and document development processes and
create a self-documenting system
devops certification course will also
cover Advanced tools like puppet soft
stack and ansible that will help
self-governance and automated management
at scale link is mentioned in the
description do check it out
in conclusion devops is a highly
rewarding career path with ample
opportunities for growth and advancement
by following the roadmap discussed
before you can acquire the necessary
skills and knowledge to succeed in this
field well this was the end of the video
on how to choose devops as a career if
you liked the video then please give it
a thumbs up and share it with your
friends also if you have any questions
related to this video then please feel
free to ask away in the comment section
our team will reach out to you as soon
as possible thank you and keep learning
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here